bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat ce matin les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen du budget pour 2015
après avoir adopté la première partie la
semaine dernière première partie
consacrée aux recettes et cela faisait
deux ans que cela n'était pas arrivé au
sénat eh bien les sénateurs s'attaquer
cela depuis vendredi dernier aux crédits
d'émission c'est à dire aux dépenses une
par une
ce matin place à l'enseignement
supérieur et à la recherche
un budget en baisse comme c'est le cas
pour de nombreux budgets mais cela
notamment après l'adoption à la dernière
minute et avec l'accord du gouvernement
par l'assemblée nationale au mois de
novembre d'amendements qui ont baissé
encore ce budget - 71 millions d'euros
sur l'enseignement supérieur et -65
millions d'euros environ sur le budget
de la recherche
une situation qui a été déploré au mois
de novembre par les présidents
d'université qui ont des noces évident à
un communiqué une politique en décalage
avec les déclarations
rappelons que françois hollande a fait
de la jeunesse l'une des priorités de
son quinquennat
d'ailleurs ici au sénat eh bien tous
partis confondus et bien il ya un
consensus pour revenir à la version
initiale de ce budget pourrait abonder
ce budget de 135 millions d'euros
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui illustre et bien
l'amendement qui a été cosigné par les
rapporteurs de la commission de la
culture à la fois l'ump jacques
grosperrin et la socialiste dominique
gillot tout de suite donc place à la
séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la cites de la
discussion du projet de loi de finances
pour 2015 adopté par l'assemblée
nationale
le sénat va examiner les crédits de la
mission recherche et enseignement
supérieur
la parole est à monsieur philippe
anneaux rapporteur général de la
commission pardon rapporteur spécial de
la commission des finances vous avez la
parole vous chers collègues bien madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
dans sa version initiale tel qu'issu du
projet de loi de finances pour 2015
déposé à l'assemblée nationale la
mission recherche et enseignement
supérieur bénéficiait d'un budget plus
que préserver avec 25,9 milliards
d'euros en autorisations d'engagement et
26 milliards d'euros en crédits de
paiement les dépenses fiscales
rattachées à la mission à titre
principal s'élève quant à elle à 6,4
milliards d'euros dont 5,3 au titre du
crédit d'impôt recherche
cette stabilité des crédits confirmait
le caractère prioritaire que le
gouvernement souhaitait conférer à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche d'ailleurs la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
prévoyait également le maintien de l'
enveloppe accordée à la mission pour
2015 mais 17 orcas pensions augmenter de
100 millions d'euros d'ici à 2017
j'ai pu également constater que les
crédits du programme d'investissements
d'avenir constituer une importante
ressource pour les opérateurs de la
mission et qu'ils étaient susceptibles
de couvrir des dépenses qu'ils l'étaient
jusqu'à présent par des crédits
budgétaires ce qui ne paraît pas
convenable toutefois lors de son examen
à l'assemblée nationale une coupe de 136
millions d'euros a été opéré en seconde
délibération sur les crédits de la
mission afin de garantir la norme de
dépense en valeur de l'état avec une
baisse de 70 millions d'euros sur le
programme 150 dédié à l'enseignement
supérieur et le reste pour les
programmes de la recherche
cette importante réduction des crédits
et ses conséquences tant pour les
opérateurs de l'enseignement supérieur
que pour les organismes de recherche
concernés a conduit la commission des
finances a proposé de ne pas adopter des
crédits de la mission
alors qu'elle était auparavant prononcés
en faveur de leur adoption et j'y
reviendrai le budget consacré à
l'enseignement supérieur qui comprend à
la fois le programme 150 et le programme
231 correspond à 15,2 milliards d'euros
en autorisations d'engagement et 15,3
milliards d'euros en crédits de paiement
dans le projet de loi de finance tel que
présenté par le gouvernement lui sont 40
millions d'euros seront consacrés au
financement de l'immobilier
universitaire dans le cadre des contrats
de plan état région 2015-2020 140
millions d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement et 17 millions d'euros en
crédits de paiement sont inscrits à ce
titre pour 2015 concernant le programme
150 des moyens supplémentaires devaient
être alloués aux universités et aux
autres établissements publics avec 11,8
milliards d'euros prévue pour 2015 les
crédits de la masse salariale des
établissements ayant accédé aux
responsabilités et compétences élargies
augmentait ainsi de plus de 150 millions
d'euros afin de couvrir principalement
la création de 1000 emplois en 2015
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république d'en créer
5000 au cours de son quinquennat
cette enveloppe qui ré également les
conséquences de mesures prises par le
gouvernement en faveur des agents de la
fonction publique et prenez en compte
pour la première fois dans la dotation
initiale de l'état une partie des effets
du glissement vieillesse technicité
toutefois comme indiqué précédemment les
crédits du programme 150 ont été réduits
de 70 millions d'euros par l'assemblée
nationale en seconde délibération
cette somme devait selon le gouvernement
être supportés par les opérateurs du
programme grâce à la réalisation
d'économies or le projet de loi de
finances prévoyait déjà un effort de 100
millions d'euros demandé aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
au titre de leur participation au
redressement des finances publiques
cette nouvelle réduction des crédits est
regrettable et critiquable alors que les
établissements publics d'enseignement
supérieur semblait retrouver une
situation plus saine depuis leur passage
à l'autonomie et que le gouvernement
paraissent
avoir fait l'effort de tenir compte au
moins pour partie des charges qu'il
faisait porter sur eux cette réduction
de crédits remet tout en cause
l'essentiel de la subvention pour
charges de service public créé couvrons
en réalité des dépenses de personnel
comment monsieur le ministre avant
j'avais mis madame la ministre mais je
suppose que vous connaissez le sujet par
coeur monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous financer les 1000 emplois
en 2015
s'agissant de ces mille emplois par an
justement rien ne garantit que les
universités utilisent réellement ces
crédits pour recruter des effectifs
supplémentaires on sait tous comment ça
se passe c'est à dire qu'en réalité les
universités utilisent les postes pour
des variables d'ajustement financiers et
les emplois 1 peuvent effectivement être
prévu est en réalité ne pas être mis du
tout en oeuvre si on fait une analyse
globale je craint également que des
dépenses de fonctionnement
supplémentaires ne se créé par les
communes et j'espère qu'un nombre limité
d emploi ouvert leur seront affectés les
communes ne doit pas non plus conduire à
ce que certains établissements de petite
taille voient leurs moyens réduits en
raison de leur plus faible
représentation au sein de ces
communautés et j'espère que dans le
cadre du cp vert on ne verra pas les
grandes universités s'attribuer
l'essentiel des crédits au détriment des
entités plus petites
monsieur le ministre j'espère que vous
pourrez nous rassurer sur ce point il
n'y avait que sept établissements en
déficit à la fin de l'exercice 2013 même
si quelques universités rencontre encore
des difficultés importantes
il semble qu'elles aient toutes pris la
mesure de leur autonomie en disposant
désormais des moyens humains et
techniques nécessaires pour l'exercer la
commission des finances ne manquera pas
de s'intéresser de près à ce sujet
puisqu'elle recevra au printemps
prochain
l'enquète qu'elle a commandés auprès de
la cour des comptes dans le cadre de
l'article 58 de la lolf sur le bilan de
l'autonomie financière des universités
je considère pour ma part que certains
établissements parviennent actuellement
à maintenir leur équilibre financier au
prix d'économies considérables
certains établissements d'ailleurs nous
ont alertés sur les importantes pertes
de recettes induites à
la réforme de la taxe d'apprentissage la
collecte de certains d'entre eux
pourraient être ainsi divisée par deux
alors que cette reprise de ressources
représentent jusqu'à 30 % de leur budget
je souhaite maintenant m'arrêter
quelques instants sur la situation des
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur privé dans la dotation
s'établit à 78 9 millions d'euros dans
le projet de loi de finances et connaît
une nouvelle baisse de 1% alors qu'elle
a déjà diminué de 12% entre 2012 et 2015
la participation moyenne de l'état est
ainsi passée de 1000 euros par étudiant
en 2013 à seulement 8 116 en 2014 la
réduction de leurs crédits pourrait même
être plus importante c'est la coupes
budgétaires opérées lors de la seconde
délibération à l'assemblée nationale
devait leur être répercuté ce qui risque
d'être le cas j'espère que non en effet
avec soixante dix neuf mille étudiants à
ce prix ces établissements jouent un
rôle essentiel dans la diversité des
parcours et pour un coût mineurs pour
l'état si demain l'état devait avoir
soixante dix neuf mille étudiants de
plus l'effort financier serait bien sûr
beaucoup plus important lors de l'examen
de la mission la commission des finances
avait adopté un amendement sur ma
proposition tendant à maintenir le
montant de l'enveloppé de la dotation
qui leur était alloué à son montant de
2014 majoré de 1 %
toutefois la seconde délibération de
l'assemblée nationale ayant conduit la
commission des finances à ne plus
adopter les crédits l'amendement n'a pas
prospéré et je vous le proposerai
toutefois à titre personnel tout à
l'heure pour finir nous attendons
toujours la réforme du dispositif sympa
qui devrait permettre une meilleure
allocation des moyens dès 2015
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
indiquer où on en est à l'heure actuelle
en contrepartie des 1000 allocation
nouvelles qui sont prévus dans le cadre
du fonds national d'urgence
il est indispensable que le contrôle de
l'assiduité aux cours et à la présence
aux examens sont effectivement assurée
je poursuis actuellement un contrôle
budgétaire à ce sujet et j'en tiendrai
informé la haute assemblée je regrette
et je crois que ce sentiment est
largement partagé
la suppression de l'aide au mérite par
le gouvernement considérant que
l'excellence doit être valorisée cette
aide concerne d'ailleurs sa vocation
sociale puisqu'elle n'est versée qu'à
des étudiants disposant d'une bourse sur
critères sociaux
j'espère que vous changerez d'avis
monsieur le ministre et que vous
conserverez ce symbole fort de la
méritocratie
au total le programme 231 augmente de 1
7% en crédits de paiement pour atteindre
2,5 milliards d'euros
cette évolution ne devrait pour autant
pas permettre d'éviter une nouvelle fois
la ligne consacrée aux aides directes
connaissent une soupe budgétisation
compte tenu de l'ensemble des éléments
que je viens d'évoquer de la réduction
des crédits de 136 millions d'euros par
l'assemblée nationale la commission des
finances vous propose de ne pas adopter
les cris de la mission recherche et
enseignement supérieur
mesdames messieurs je vous remercie
merci monsieur adnot la parole et à
monsieur michel berson rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente
mes chers collègues le dynamisme et la
qualité de notre recherche constitue un
enjeu essentiel pour notre pays
investir dans la recherche aujourd'hui
c'est préparer la croissance de demain
la politique publique de la recherche a
donc vocation à soutenir la recherche et
parfois à l'orienter l'effort public en
faveur de la recherche peut d'abord est
appréciée au regard des crédits alloués
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais en
premier lieu esquissé les grandes lignes
du budget de la recherche pour 2015 et
je vais préciser que les crédits alloués
à la recherche ne sont pas tous
regroupés dans le programme dit
recherche de la mission recherche et
enseignement supérieur
l'action recherche du programme 150
formation et recherche universitaire que
vient de présenter notre collègue
philippe adnot et doté de 3,8 milliards
d'euros en 2015
en prenant en compte ce montant le total
des crédits en faveur de la recherche
s'élèverait à 14,4 milliards d'euros mon
analyse ce contre se concentrera sur les
progrès les programmes de la mission
spécifiquement orientée vers la
recherche et qui s'élève à 10,6
milliards d'euros mais une approche
purement quantitative ne saurait suffire
à comprendre pleinement les défis
auxquels la recherche est aujourd'hui
confronté je proposerai donc ensuite
quelques pistes de réflexion sur les
problématiques auxquelles doit faire
face la recherche française la rédaction
initiale du projet de loi de finances
pour 2015
conduit à une relative stabilisation des
crédits alloués à la recherche dans la
mesure où l'heure est au redressement
des comptes publics
cette préservation relative des moyens
alloués à la recherche nous paraît
traduire la priorité accordée par le
gouvernement aux dépenses d'avenir
en effet dans la rédaction initiale du
projet de loi de finances pour 2015 les
crédits ne connaîtraient pas ou ne
connaîtra qu'une baisse modérée
inférieure à 1%
quant au budget triennal à venir 2015
2017 qui devrait également voir la
stabilisation des crédits de la
recherche
deux programmes dépendent du ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche le programme 172 recherche
scientifique et technologique
pluridisciplinaire qui concentre
l'essentiel des opérateurs de recherche
publique et bénéficie d'environ 60 % des
crédits alloués au programme recherche
et le programme 193 recherche spatiale
hier se tenait au luxembourg une réunion
de l'agencé spatiale européenne qui
devait décider de l'avenir du programme
ariane
je me réjouis de l'accord historique
auquel les partenaires européens sont
parvenus pour développer le nouveau
lanceur ariane 6 dans ce programme de 4
milliards d'euros
la france s'est engagée à hauteur de 52%
et l'allemagne 2 22%
la france a conforté sa position de
leader européen et tous les pays du
programme sont désormais à même de
continuer à construire ensemble une
politique spatiale susceptible de
résister au redoutable concurrent
américain space x et de garantir à
l'europe son autonomie d'accès à
l'espace le programme 190 recherche dans
les domaines de l'énergie du
développement et de la mobilité durable
rattaché au ministère de l'écologie
bénéficie d'un financement élevés avec
1,4 milliard d'euros de crédits pour
2015 et les quatre autres programmes
restant attachés à différents ministères
la défense la culture l'agriculture
l'économie et l'industrie sont également
dotés d'un montant total de crédit de
1,4 milliard d'euros
si j'ai donc d'abord observé avec
satisfaction la stabilisation des
crédits de la recherche
j'ai regretté ensuite que cette
préservation soit remise en cause
les crédits des programmes de recherche
ont été en effet réduit à hauteur de 66
millions d'euros par un amendement du
gouvernement adopté par l'assemblée
nationale dans le cadre d'une seconde
délibération sur la deuxième partie du
projet de loi de finances pour 2015 la
commission des finances du sénat qui
avait d'abord adopter les crédits les a
finalement rejeté en réseau de cette
minoration cette réduction est d'autant
plus regrettable
monsieur le ministre quel fait qu à des
annulations de crédits importants pour
la fin de gestion 2014 intervenu par
décret d'avancé sur cette même mission
ce sont en effet près de 200 millions
d'euros en autorisations d'engagement et
264 millions d'euros en crédits de
paiement qui ont été annulés comme le
président de la république je dirais que
les dépenses de recherche doivent être
sanctuarisés
ce sont elles qui permettent
l'innovation dont le savons bien qu'elle
est devenue aujourd'hui le moteur de la
croissance
je souhaite donc monsieur le ministre
que soient rétablies
les 66 millions d'euros de crédits
prévus initialement dans le projet de
loi de finances pour 2015
au delà de la nécessaire préservation
des crédits de la recherche
j'aimerais désormais évoqué rapidement
trois enjeux qui me paraissent
structurants pour l'avenir
notre recherche tout d'abord force est
de constater qu'en france le financement
de la recherche par projets peinent à
émerger
il représente or pay a tout au plus 10 %
des crédits du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche au niveau national l'érosion
des projets financés par l' agence
nationale de recherches montrent que les
progrès sont nécessaires
certes après avoir diminué les crédits
alloués à l'anah sont maintenant
stabilisés mais à un niveau qui nous
paraît à la limite de l'opérationnalité
il ne s'agit pas d'augmenter à tout prix
les financements sur projets au
détriment des crédits récurrents mais de
trouver le bon équilibre entre ces deux
modes de financement autres kiliba
réalisé 80% des projets sélectionnés par
la leyre la nr relève de la recherche
fondamentale
aussi certains opérateurs souhaitent il
que ce pourcentage baisse au profit de
la recherche technologique
la fixation d'un précipice véritablement
compatible avec les frais de
fonctionnement d'un laboratoire est en
outre nécessaire pour éviter l' asphyxie
de nos organismes de recherche
si l'augmentation récente du préciput
doit être saluée démarche de progrès
là aussi sont encore possibles le
programme d'investissements d'avenir a
permis de lancer des projets ambitieux
et constitue de notre point de vue une
réussite
toutefois pour cette période de
contraintes budgétaires fortes
il faut rappeler que les pays acp
doivent rester des programmes innovants
tourné vers l'excellence hainaut se
substituer à des dotations budgétaires
au niveau européen la france ne semble
pas avoir tiré tous les bénéfices des
différents programmes de recherche de
l'union européenne le performances
apparaissent insuffisante au regard des
capacités de la recherche française et
dans la mesure où la france est le
deuxième contributeur
au budget de l'union européenne le
programme horizon 20 20 est maintenant
dotée en france d'un accompagnement
renforcé des chercheurs ce dont il faut
se féliciter
cependant ce dispositif ne semble pas
encore avoir produit tous ses résultats
la france avec une contribution de 16
26% au budget aurait en effet obtenu un
peu moins de 10% des financements
accordés aux lauréats des 38 premiers
appels à projets du programme horizon 20
20 quant au niveau local l'effort du
gouvernement dans les nouveaux contrats
de plan état région 2015 2020 doit être
reconnu même s'il demeure limitée eu
égard aux contrats précédents et aux
futures compétences renforcées des
régions
le deuxième défi concerne la
complémentarité entre recherche publique
et recherche privée alors que la
recherche publique et financé de façon
lisible et transparente par dotation
budgétaire la recherche privée est
soutenu par l'état à travers des aides
publiques mais surtout 14 dépenses
fiscales dont le coût global s'élèverait
à environ 6 milliards d'euros en 2015
le crédit d'impôt recherche représentant
près de 90% de ce total l'effet
attractif du cir auprès des entreprises
internationales n'est plus à démontrer
de même que son effet de levier un euro
de cir générant 1 euros 32 recherches
supplémentaires mais il convient de
souligner que l'effort de recherche des
entreprises françaises restent
insuffisants alors même que les soutiens
de l'état à la recherche privée est
important aussi plusieurs pistes
devraient être exploités pour que le
crédit d'impôt recherche soit
parallèlement plus favorable aux
organismes publics de recherche et al
embauche de docteur d'une part les
dépenses privées de recherche sous
traité à des organismes publics sont
actuellement plafonné dans l'assiette du
ir à 12 millions d'euros par entreprise
pour favoriser le recours des
entreprises privées à la recherche
publique
ce plafond pourrait être relevée à 20
millions d'euros
d'autre part le taux de cire de 5%
appliquée aux dépenses de recherche
supérieur à 100 millions d'euros
pourrait être conditionnée à la
conclusion de contrats de recherche avec
des organismes publics ou à l'embauché
de docteurs en 2012 le nombre de
docteurs recruté par les entreprises
s'est élevé à 1305 si ce chiffre a
triplé en cinq ans il reste faible quand
on sait que 12000 docteur sont diplômés
chaque année et que la recherche
publique y compris l'enseignement
supérieur en recrutent 2500 je voudrais
par ailleurs rappelé monsieur le
ministre
une autre dépense fiscale la taxation à
taux réduit des plus values de cession
de brevets à un coût élevé de l'ordre de
400 millions d'euros en 2014
son efficacité nous le savons n'est pas
pleinement justifiée aussi je propose
que cette dépense fiscale soit supprimé
les marges de manoeuvre dégagées
pourrait alors être réalloués en faveur
d'un plan de relance de l'emploi
scientifique qui nous paraît nécessaire
oui madame la présidente je vais
conclure en disant quelques mots
seulement du troisième défi l'emploi
scientifique qui rend compte aujourd'hui
de grandes difficultés bien que les
plafonds dans le poids des programmes de
recherche ne connaissent pas de
diminution significative plusieurs
opérateurs pour faire remarquer que ces
plafonds n'était pas atteint souvent
raison de resserrement des crédits des
laboratoires et ils m'ont tous fait
également part des difficultés à
maintenir leurs programmes de
recrutement en témoignent nos musées de
personnels contractuels et le fait que
les départs à la retraite en réduction
ne permettent plus des embauches en
nombre suffisant matériaux mon dernier
mot en à me la présidente pour
satisfaire d'avoir fortement vraiment
concluant la maintenant monsieur
il me paraît primordial de conserver
l'emploi scientifique de qualité les
pistes que je viens d'exquis c'est
permettrait d'y contribuer et je pense
que grâce à une meilleure reconnaissance
du doctorat dans les conventions
collectives et la fonction publique et
grâce à une sanctuarisation j'y reviens
des finances publiques
nous pourrions atteindre cet objectif
sous les bénéfices de ces observations
la commission des finances a décidé de
rejeter les crédits de la mission merci
michel à l'adduction des crédits
intervenu en seconde délibération de
l'assemblée la super si monsieur la
botte spéciale
monsieur carrère pour rappel le
règlement
vous avez la parole oui madame la
présidente je vous remercie tout d'abord
je ne sais pas exactement sur quel
chapitre du règlement intérieur s'appuie
où se fonde mon rappel au règlement
monsieur le ministre il s'agit de
l'ordonnancement des orateurs je
voudrais savoir si je n'ai rien contre
valérie létard je tiens à le préciser
c'est même tout tout tout le contraire
mais je suis un peu étonné que la
commission de la culture soit relégué un
petit peu derrière alors que c'est la
commission qui portent quand même la
recherche et l'enseignement supérieur
alors ça me paraît pas tout à fait
logique
si c'est une histoire dont
d'alphabétisme je pensais qu ici on
pouvait trouver quand même des fonds
demandent un peu plus prestigieux que
l'ovale fab éthiques
ça me paraîtrait quand même une capacité
des uns et des autres de réfléchir un
petit peu et je tiens à défendre la
commission des affaires de la culture
qui prête au fond de toutes ces choses
là très bien mon cher collègue
je prends acte
si vous me permettez de répondre
monsieur assouline
donc c'est effectivement dans le
règlement la l'ordre alphabétique mais
je m'engage en tant que vice-présidente
à relayer votre remarque au bureau et à
la conférence des présidents
et je vous donnerai la suite de cette
remarque
voilà donc pardonnez moi mais
aujourd'hui ce sera quand même
madame valérie létard qui aura la parole
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires économiques
vous avez la parole madame madame et à
bombay je n'y suis pour rien bah écoute
et peut-être qu'on a revu l'alphabet vol
je m'engage à relayer cette remarque à
la conférence des présidents
et maintenant je vous demande mes chers
collègues de bien vouloir écouter madame
létard merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
mon intervention portera plus
spécifiquement sur le volet recherche de
la mairesse et j'essaierai d'aller droit
au but et ne m'attarderai pas sur les
crédits si ce n'est pour regretter bien
évidemment la ponction de 135,5 millions
d'euros qui a été fait que qu'a effectué
le gouvernement en deuxième délibération
à l'assemblée nationale en vue de
financer les emplois aidés
certes la recherche n'est pas la seule
touchée aux côtés de l'enseignement
supérieur et il conviendra d'ailleurs de
voir précisément sur quels postes
porteront ces prélèvements
mais comment ne pas déplorer que l'on
prenne sur des projets de recherche et
d'innovation qui doivent permettre des
ris de d'éviter demain le de recours à
de tels emplois qui sont certainement
très utile mais à notre sens pas à
fonctionner sur quelque chose qui va
préparer les emplois de demain cela dans
un contexte où plus que jamais la r&d
conditionne directement notre
compétitivité
et l'avenir de notre industrie quel est
le sens d'une telle démarche et d'un tel
choix budgétaires alors sur cette
question il ya bien sûr un paradoxe
monsieur le ministre sur lequel le
gouvernement devrait s'expliquer et nous
dire s'il compte rétablir la situation
et remettre cette somme au budget comme
le propose d'ailleurs par voie
d'amendement nos collègues de la
commission culture que je m'empresse de
saluer à cette occasion deux mots
également pour évoquer la situation
limite dans laquelle se trouvent nombre
d'organismes de recherche du fait de
leurs baisses de dotations d'état
sign on y ajoute les obligations de mise
en réserve mais aussi les mesures de
régulation budgétaire on parvient des
situations d'impasse financière alors
que leur mission ne cesse de s'élargir
ceux ci peuvent ceux qui le peuvent
pardon peuvent accroître leurs
ressources propres mais cela les place
dans une situation de dépendance
vis-à-vis des partenaires privés pour
ceux qui ne peuvent valoriser leurs
activités pas d'autre solution que de
tailler dans les moyens de
fonctionnement
à commencer bien sûr par les effectifs
voire arrêter ou renoncé à des
programmes de recherche comme certains
d'entre nous l'ont signalé
est ce là vraiment la meilleure façon de
préparer l'avenir de notre recherche
monsieur le ministre ce qu'il me semble
ne pas constituer la marque de fabrique
de notre pays
le génie français sa capacité à porter
sa force de valeur ajoutée c'est
véritablement ce qu'il nous faut
défendre pour l'avenir j'en viens au
présent thème principal du rapport pour
avis le volet recherche des contrats de
plan état région des contrats de projets
la cinquième génération de contrats de
plan 2007-2014 s'achève cette année la
sixième est en cours de finalisation
c'est un enjeu fort pour la
territorialisation de programmes de
recherche et d'innovation en lien avec
les collectivités des acteurs du
développement économique il nombre de
nos grands organismes de recherche il
émarge dans toutes nos régions et vont
ils chercher la capacité à créer des
partenariats avec le tissu économique et
territoriale or les perspectives
avancées par le gouvernement pour les
contrats de projets 2014 2020 sont
préoccupantes quant au volet de
recherche
l' enveloppe de l'état est bien
évidemment en recul fort et sur
certaines régions très très touché je
prends l'exemple de la mienne mais je
sais que beaucoup m'ont été remonté avec
des situations extrêmement inquiétante
ma région nord pas de calais verrait sa
dotation diviser par dix le mandat
négociations initiales mettez un montant
de 2 8 millions d'euros pour la
recherche pour un territoire de 4
millions d'habitants
voilà comment avec des moyens aussi
faible accompagner des projets de r&d
structurant pour des filières d'avenir
en partenariat avec les organismes de
recherche concernés et le tissu
industriel
il ne faut pas oublier non plus que ces
financements servent de base pour
obtenir des co financements européens
malgré l' enveloppe de supplémentaire de
150 millions d'euros sur le volet
enseignement supérieur et recherche de
ces contrats de projets qu'a décidé le
gouvernement lit le compte est loin d'y
être malheureusement j'ai donc cherché à
déposer un amendement transférant une
centaine de millions d'euros
supplémentaires vers le volet recherche
des contrats de plan mais bien
évidemment nous ne pouvons pour des
raisons techniques car seul le
gouvernement à la main en effet sur une
telle décision
aussi voudrais-je obtenir monsieur le
ministre l'engagement que soit inscrite
une nouvelle action dans les programmes
172 et 192 finançant ce volet recherche
des contrats de projet est doté d'une
centaine de millions
c'est financement pourrait provenir du
pays à qui poursuit bien les mêmes
objectifs
simplement elle serait territorialisée
assurerait la pérennité des projets déjà
lancés dans le cadre de ces contrats de
projets en rattrapant les inégalités
existantes entre les régions
à défaut un coup d'arrêt risque fort
d'être porté à cette dynamique qui
conditionne la compétitivité l'emploi de
nos territoires
voilà monsieur madame le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les analyses et propositions que m'ont
inspiré cet avis recherche
notre commission a fait preuve
d'ouverture en y donnant un avis de
sagesse et non défavorable d'emblée
attendant la position du gouvernement
quant au rétablissement de des 135
millions d'euros mais aussi sur son
ouverture sur l'europe
page des contrats de projets jeu bien
évidemment pour ma part je déterminerai
donc ma position après avoir entendu
monsieur le ministre est bien évidemment
vu et comment attendu le résultat des
votes sur le rétablissement du budget à
ce moment là bien évidemment
eh bien nous pourrons voir comment le
gouvernement souhaite à l'avenir et bien
défendre sa politique de recherche la
défendre fermement les emplois aidés
sont certainement un moyen d'accompagner
nos politiques et bien de lutte contre
les difficultés et le chômage que nous
connaissons mais en aucun cas il faut le
faire au nom des emplois de demain et au
nom de l'avenir de la recherche
merci madame la ministre monsieur
jacques grosperrin rapporteur pour avis
de la commission de la culture à la
parole maintenant vous avez la parole
vous chers collègues
c'est grand
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mais c'est
le ministre je mesure la difficulté qui
est la vôtre
il n'est pas facile de défendre un
budget présenté comme sanctuariser est
prioritaire lorsque bercy guettent la
moindre source d'économies en ces temps
de disette budgétaire
je ne tiens pas à diaboliser ni accabler
la direction du budget qui sous la
pression intense de la cour des comptes
comme de bruxelles cherche à rétablir
l'équilibré de nos finances publiques au
prix de sacrifices souvent douloureux à
deux moments le monde universitaire
s'est demandé si le président de la
république avait bien été sincère dans
les déclarations d'amour qui lui avait
adressé fin octobre d'abord quand la cpu
s'est ému que le dernier versement par
l'état aux universités de leurs
dotations annuelles ne correspondent
qu'à 80% du montant qui leur avait été
initialement notifiés avec le risque que
les établissements ne soient